let's talk a little bit about the
conservation of angular momentum and
this is going to be really useful
because it explains diverse phenomena in
the universe from Y and ice skaters
angular speed goes up when they tuck
their arms or their legs in all the way
to when you have something orbiting
around a star and the closer and closer
it spirals in it seems like it's
rotational velocities angular speed is
picking up and it starts to rotate
faster and faster around the body you'll
see that if you see simulations of estra
astronomical phenomena so the big
picture here is is if we have our
initial angular momentum for a system
and we'll think about that a little bit
no matter as long as the system has no
external torque applied to it then your
final angular momentum is going to be
the exact same thing and so one way to
think about it let's imagine that I have
some type of spinning thing over here I
have some type of mass let's say it's on
a table I'm looking from above and a
point on the outside of this disc is
spinning in this direction with a
velocity of magnitude V and let's say
that there's a clump of clay of orange
maybe it's play-doh or clay or something
and it has a velocity going in this
direction it's not a collision course
with this object and let's say it has a
velocity of 5 V and so if we think about
the this disc clay clump system and so
you always have to specify what system
you are talking about so if you think
about this entire system how does the
angular momentum change before these two
things collide and then after these two
things collide so actually let me draw
that after the collision scenario so the
after the collision scenario it looks
something like this where the clay has
now clumped on to this and now they are
going to be rotating together and I
haven't even told you the mass of this
disc or the mass of this clay so it
would be unclear in which direction they
would now
be rotating but how is the angular
momentum going to change from this state
from the initial state to the final
state pause this video and try to think
about it well you might have guessed
since we said look we have this whole
system and we're not applying any
external torque to the system our
angular momentum is going to stay
exactly the same now we have to be
careful if I told you the system was
just this disc not the clay clump that's
on a collision course with it then the
angular momentum for the disc would
change but why is that does that defy
the conservation of angular momentum no
because this clay clump when it collides
would be providing an external torque to
the system if we define the system to
just be the disc but since it's the disc
plus the clay clump and we have no
external torque to that combined system
then our angular momentum is not going
to change now that we can appreciate
that angular momentum is constant as
long as that there is no net torque
applied to the system let's think about
the famous situation where an ice skater
angular speed goes up as they tuck in
their arms and you can do a less
graceful version of this on an office
chair where if you sit on the office
chair and you begin spinning this is my
office chair and if you stick your legs
out at first you're going to spin slowly
but then if you tuck your legs in then
you're going to start spinning faster
you're going to have a higher angular
speed now why is that well to appreciate
that we can think about the formula for
angular momentum so the formula for
angular momentum L there's a couple of
ways we can or several ways that we
could write that we could write that as
our moment of inertia I times our
angular speed times Omega and this might
look a little bit foreign at first to
you but it has a complete a now analog
when we're dealing in the linear world
here we're rotating in the linear world
we say that linear momentum is equal
to mass is equal to mass times velocity
and the reason why we have an analogue
here is mass can tell you about inertia
of an object how much force you need to
apply to accelerate that object F equals
MA
well moment of inertia you have
something similar going on but instead
of thinking about how to just linearly
accelerate something this tells you how
hard is it to get angular acceleration
how much torque do you need to apply
instead of just how much linear force
you to apply and instead of velocity you
have angular speed and sometimes this is
called angular velocity as well but this
by itself you might say well this
doesn't help me when I'm tucking in my
knees when I'm on an office chair or the
ice skater tucking in her arms well to
think about that we just have to
appreciate that the moment of inertia
can be expressed as M times radius
squared M R squared and then we still
have our Omega right over here so this
is another way of writing angular
momentum and so when a skater tucks in
her arms her mass is not changing that
is staying constant but remember the
radius one way to think about it a
little complicated when you're thinking
about a human body system in a simple
sense if you just have a point mass
rotating around a point like that then
this is the radius but if we're dealing
with a more complicated structure like a
human body you can imagine the radius as
being indicative of the average distance
of the mass from the center of rotation
and so when the figure skater tucks in
her arms that average distance goes down
and so when she tucks in her arm this
goes down but if this part goes down but
our angular momentum stays constant
because we have no torque being applied
to the system no net torque being
applied to the system well then this
needs to go up in order to keep that
angular momentum constant and that's
exactly what's happening the angular
speed picks up just as the radius goes
down now this also explains why if you
have let's say that's some type of a
planet and you have a rock or something
orbiting it as this gets closer and
closer to the planet it's going to its
angular speed is going to go higher and
higher and higher why is that
well because when you have a high radius
so here your radius is higher and so
your angular speed might be a little bit
lower but then when you're closer in
when you're closer in your radius has
gone down and so your angular speed has
to go up to make for up has to go up to
make up for it I'll leave you there I
encourage you to have fun spinning on
office chairs